all right so the bad batch season 2
episode 5 is now out in this video we're
gonna be breaking down the new episode
talking about all the Star Wars Easter
eggs in it and the hidden details you
might have missed in the 20 minute entry
there's clear allusions to Indiana Jones
The Fifth Element and even a bit of
horizon zero Dawn I think and a calm way
to get into it first though blah blah
blah thumbs up blah blah blah without
the way I'm your host Paul AKA Benedict
Cumberbatch now let's get into the video
now the episode is called entombed and
we start off very much in the same way
that we end we catch the bad batch in a
junkyard which is later married by the
destruction that we see in the final few
scenes here we catch Omega and wrecker
hunting for parts which is when she
comes across a dial that works as a
compass this ends up being similar to a
Sith wayfinder which we saw kylo using
at the start of Rise of Skywalker which
we don't talk about now you might notice
that wrecker even has more color in his
uniform this episode it shows how
they're slowly diverting from the
Imperial mentality I've discussed this
in our other videos and the Empire very
much have the color dialed down to being
gray black and white even Commander Cody
who done orange in the movies has had
his stuff scale back to being gray
whereas the bad batch of gained more
color the shows either Breaking Free and
becoming more rebellious refusing to
conform to the lack of diversity in the
Empire's uniforms and they also get a
compressor and this looks like it's from
an ATR 6 assault transport from here we
go to Sid's parlor to catch Wonder
sykes's Fiji Noah Noah of course I don't
know her I just met her
now she's spinning a yawn to the weak
way and I thorian who I I only learned
last week are actually called catching
bolo this idea of going off in a wild
story is very much built in a fee's
character and come the end of the
episode we see her back to our old
Triggs doing the same thing to Amiga we
learned she's a pirate that refers to
herself as a treasure hunter and this is
very much mirrored in Dr Aphra Afra made
her debut in the Darth Vader comics and
she's often described as being Star Wars
answer to Indiana Jones he tells them a
story about an octomorph pulling her
down and the weights described makes it
sound like an offshoot species of a
dinoga these giant sea spiders grabbed
Lucan and you hope and you even fought
one in Shadows of the Empire she talks
about how she managed to get a pearl
from one and these being inside
creatures is something that we've also
seen in the case of crate dragons they
have them inside their stomachs and at
the end of the first episode of the
Mandalorian season 2 we saw one being
fished out after piling the scraps on
the Holodeck we hear they've got a
regulator which was a component in Star
Wars that was used on jet packs about
what catches These Eyes is of course the
compass devices like these are of course
used throughout fiction and they're
often put in place to help to progress
the story we've seen it in the
aforementioned wayfinder and also the
way this device Works reminds me a lot
of the one from Raiders of the Lost Ark
it's spherical and once the Droid shines
a light through it it reveals certain
aspects like the staff of raw C3PO and
R2D2 even appeared in wall markings in
the movie showing how it's organic
a thesis is from the caldar trinary
system which is off the map she says the
best Treasures usually aren't found on
them and if you cast your mind back to
attack of the Clones then you'll
remember that Camino was removed from
the Jedi Archives this is where the
Clones were from making them the best
treasures and it's sort of like poetry
they Rhyme now a trinary system likely
means three Suns and in a new hope we
saw how taroene was located in a binary
one a touchdown we can see that the land
is being raised and that is now
completely uninhabitable Scorch marks
line the ground and these four Shadow
the destructive power that will see
unleash later on upon arriving there the
compass activates and it starts to lead
the way back the big giraffe poor thingy
a huge announce to our edit a map for
pointing out that the planet is very
menacing and Echoes dathomir which we
explored heavily in fall in order the
markings on the tree and overall
eeriness mirror that without being
potential threats around every corner
the episode also pulls heavily from the
puzzles in that game namely the ones
that you run into on zeppo and helium
weirdly I was watching The Fifth Element
the other night and the stones in that
all had line markings on them to know
what it required to activate these two
appear on the handles poking out the
wall and it might not be intentional but
but it's just something I noticed
because I've been watching Ruby right my
man Ruby Rod gobit my man
I think back thousands of years ago this
machine predates the Jedi possibly being
around the time of the Jed high this was
the order that preceded them and its
engine technology was lost to time it
may be before that but they delved
deeper into the heart of the mountain
with the music even riffing on John
Williams original writer score he of
course also composed the music for Star
Wars so his music lens itself very
nicely to the scene the whole place is
booby-trapped and they get stuck inside
before a Megabus at the compass to allow
them to go further as they Venture in
they're attacked by giant underwater
creatures who live in the caverns and
stalk the landscape outside kinda
reminded me of the spiders from Lost in
Space which sorry for reminding you that
that movie exists I apologize now the
tunnels themselves are also similar to
caverns in Pitch Black and aliens with
these creatures moving in the shadows
and chasing them through in a node to
the Last Crusade we see Hunter making
his way across a tile floor and this
collapses similar to the way it did in
the movie this was then later adapted
into the Tomb Raider games and it's
become a staple of treasure hunting
films if you if you ever watch any of
them the episode isn't too full of
Easter eggs in all honesty and the ones
I've mentioned before might not even be
intentional but bits like this are of
course playing on the cliches that
always pop up in those films either way
they have to place the compass into the
wall in order to guide the way forward
it then come up on the center and this
activates upon fee removing the central
Idol again Indiana Jones Easter eggs in
the place with treasures being removed
is what often causes things to start up
here though we see a death machine
starting to walk across the land when
the machine rolls up and blasted its
horn it reminded me a lot of the War of
the Worlds especially because of the
fact it was buried underground for
thousands and thousands of years the
idea of destroying Landscapes is
something that's also been laced
throughout the season too with us
learning it happen on Dooku's home and
the empire were threatening to do did
Essex they've already done it on kamino
too and these attacks foreshadow the
Death Star seeing this destroy the
planet so easily it actually makes me
wonder if the Empire might even come
across the machine and then use it as a
way to harness the power from it it's a
long shot but seeing this constant
repetition of the land being destroyed
makes me think they're foreshadowing the
Death Star anyway rest in peace little
Mel we barely knew the now fee does say
that Mel's data banks are stored on the
ship and that they can be fixed up so of
no doubt that we'll see the little guy
back being the gang fight the creature
inside to place the treasure back and in
doing so it manages to destroy the
machine in an uncharted-esque ending
they don't get any treasure but they do
make some friends along the way which is
the most important lesson working with
beers left them oh and two so far but
they've discovered the legend was real
so meh well we have we had a good time I
guess now Hunter says it's good that no
one can ever activate the machine but I
guess we're gonna see because I'm I'm
thinking they might do some stuff with
the Death Star here anyway V starts
talking about a special chalice possibly
giving in order to the golden one that
Indie discovers when looking for the
Holy Grail we'll not get into that
though and what we will get into is is
my thoughts on the episode again and
again you know this was a really solid
one I know it's not the overarching
story it's not 10 out of 10 but yeah I
just like these nice little breaks out
let's explore the Galaxy and get to know
what the characters are like and he's
just spending some time with b and also
just a nice little cool treasure hunting
Adventure anyway and of course it's not
gonna reinvent the wheel is it it's been
been done thousands of times before but
you know for a Wednesday morning
so we'll shoot me I would of course love
to hear your thoughts on the episode so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we are in a competition right now
and giving away wakanda forever to three
subscribers on the 15th of February and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode you pick the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now
similar to you then message me on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our Brighton at The Last
of Us which will be linked on screen
right now lots of cool things to talk
about in it and hopefully I see you over
there right after that by the way thanks
for sticking through the video I've been
poor let's see you next time take care
peace